[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mulher
lamy foi o primata bíblia sociável que
tal como um homem distinto dos outros
animais pela sua capacidade linguagem
verbal e pelo seu superior o
desenvolvimento intelectual e 75 do
homem pela sua capacidade de engravidar
ser humano sexo feminino tem uma
definição simplificada diria eu da
palavra mulher mais peixes servirá como
ponto de partida para melhor entender os
mais variados contextos
aqui ela pertence àquela aspira que ela
fez isso se nós entendemos que a
diferença de gêneros
nada mais é como a única forma de
assegurar os a continuidade da espécie
mas que contudo essa diferença não deve
prevalecer em outros contextos
os tanto o homem como a mulher pertencem
à espécie humana se assim o é
eu preparo sempre com a seguinte questão
qual tem sido verdadeiramente o lugar da
mulher nos dias de hoje
a resposta isso darei mais à frente mas
fazendo um percurso histórico
vou curtir a conclusão ao que a mulher
acusada sua conhecida habilidade é tem
sido criada no sentido de servir como
uma área de conforto ao gênero oposto ou
seja criando todas as condições para que
eu sinta amado para que se tenha cuidado
com tudo tendo ela que muitas vezes
sacrificar a sua ideologia sua
identidade e principalmente os seus
sonhos e essa é uma realidade ainda
falar do nosso país embora seja mais
passivas em outras sociedades
eu acredito que ainda exista cá
por que entender e aceitar que a mulher
goza da mesma capacidade habilidade com
o homem ainda é visto como algo
atentatório à virilidade do mesmo ea
forma de revertermos esse tipo do
pensamento é a partir da educação
a forma como nós de educar os nossos
filhos e filhas
seguramente irá garantir que eles tenham
um posicionamento diferente branca essa
diferença de gêneros irá posicionar sua
forma diferentes irão pensar de uma
forma diferente e principalmente irão
atuar de uma forma diferente
enquadrado melhor que o campuseiro a
minha opção também que a nós mulheres é
exigida de forma quase permanente
o enviado da perfeição mas no que
respeita às lides domésticas um pouco de
encontro com aquilo que eu disse
inicialmente para que nós sejamos
perfeitas para um gênero oposto e nesse
sentido o curioso é que essa exigência
executiva por outras mulheres também
elas sacrificada joão portela
sacrificados
querendo a todo custo incutir uma certa
condição entre nós ainda que de forma
sutil pra ver a escola que é mais
prendada que faz melhor quem é que
domina o as receitas do bolo e tudo o
resto
eu particularmente não vejo tanto neste
disputa
eu defendo sim que as mulheres deviam
expirar serem melhores mas por elas
mesmas mas não porque tem que se colocar
à disposição terceiros porque essa é a
única forma de nós fazemos qualquer
qualquer sacrifício não pareça um fardo
às mulheres
ou seja nós devemos colocar os nossos
propósitos em primeiro lugar no centro
das nossas aspirações
só assim nós seremos melhores mães
melhores profissionais melhores amigas
esposas não só para aqueles que nos
rodeiam mas principalmente dando o
melhor de nós
há toda uma sociedade
e como é que o gum em consciência disso
está em forma como fui educada
a ênfase aí a minha de urgência foram
marcadas por uma educação que eu
considero bastante equilibrada
aí minha opinião chan foram ouvidas e
respeitadas e sempre desde cedo fizeram
a ver com a questão gêneros nunca disse
podia ser um entendimento para que o
lançar seus objetivos
eventualmente outras questões sim
financeiras saúde enfim mas esta não
porque eu poderia alcançar o mesmo
patamar com 1.100 antes quer sejam
homens ou outra mulher
a forma como fui educado e fato ter
nascido mulher com falou hoje se não
influencia todo e abre um parêntesis não
sou digamos a única filha mulher no meio
dos filhos homens mas ainda assim as
responsabilidades dos conselhos nas
advertências
elas sempre foram iguais para todos
embora ajustados a idade de cada um é
verdade mas sempre nos fizeram ver o que
contava era a forma como nós encaramos
as nossas responsabilidades e os nossos
desafios como nós nos colocava o caso
porque vamos à disposição e correr atrás
daquilo que realmente nós acreditássemos
quando feita a mente que não vai muitas
vezes quando cobrava o resultado de
algum uma tarefa ou mesmo em relação aos
estudos
eu usava o fator tempo como um protesto
por não ter conseguido 12 vezes a
resposta que o uso era citado
meu pai sempre dizia filha não se o dia
tem 24 horas do deve aprender a
confeccionar o tempo aí a gente foi tão
bem aplicado
quando comecei a fase dos namoros eu
tive até usaria dizer o pai que não se
preocupasse com namoro ia influenciar no
estudo
eu aprendi a condicionar o tempo que não
queria mais ver a expressão do meu pai e
do meu pai eu mas tudo isso para dizer
que o conceito estava lá
o conceito estava sendo disseminado
estava sendo realizado e e dessa forma
previa ver melhor a minha
responsabilidade
a esquematizar o meu cotidiano e ao
confessionário
o meu tempo bem falar um pouco mais de
mim eu terminados os estudos que quiser
tanto nem em 2010 e desde então tentei
sempre incrementar a minha vida em todos
os contextos profissional e pessoal
social enfim só posso dizer que um pouco
mais de quatro anos casey nã foi mãe de
dois meninos constituiu a empresa como
um marido que atualmente é o sócio
também constitui uma cidade advogados
como as duas colegas interessam questões
políticas
questões sociais enfim tudo isso
misturado e associados sempre com outros
trabalhos que vão surgindo dizer que lá
está a forma como ensinar o equacionar o
tempo talvez tenha sido de sempre a mais
valia para que eu conseguisse me
movimentar bem em todos os contextos
para que eu conseguisse esquematizar
tudo isso é verdade que a maternidade é
algo transformador e estou seguro acaba
com as linhas aqui eu acho que já tenha
sido mais sabem que possa haver um antes
e um depois tira é um marco é verdade
mas o lado profissional pra mim sempre
esteve muito presente e sempre contribui
em larga medida para um sentimento de
utilidade e eu acredito que seja o
grande desafio das linhas atuais têm que
se esforçar duplamente para poderem
movimentar em todos os contextos para
poderem equacionar o seu tempo e
conciliar o o seu dia a dia é certo que
sim
é o equilíbrio é chata tudo pra mim é
tão gratificante chegar a casa e ser
acolhida pelos meus filhos minha família
como também presenciar o crescimento da
minha empresa é a possibilidade da minha
empresa é ganhar uma causa ou
simplesmente poder no final do dia
confraternizar com as manias
tudo isto sem troca tudo isso se
conseguia
isto acredito ser um grande desafio e
nós mulheres atuais
corremos atrás daquilo que nós
idealizamos daquilo que nós
acreditávamos em termos que nos censos
necessariamente abrigar uma coisa e em
prol da outra ou seja aceitarmos esta
mesma condição
eu defendo que é esta simbiose aceitação
educação que realmente acham mulher faça
acontecer
mulheres que se definem o lixo que sejam
capazes de definir outras mulheres com
bons exemplos gerado um certo efeito
contágio para uma mudança de mentalidade
e consequentemente para a mudança do
paradigma em que elas estão inseridas
se assim não for é elas limitar se a uma
ser apenas donas de casa eu aqui abro
parênteses do porquê do apenas reconheço
que as mulheres que se dedicam não
fiquem exclusivamente o lar merece todo
nosso respeito por ser um trabalho árduo
em território mas estou segura que ela
não se aventurar há muito mais para além
dos preços das fraldas ou da promoção do
supermercado correrá o risco de deixar
os seus interesses ou outros interesses
bilhões simplesmente grave tem à sua
volta sem realmente agarrar sem
realmente poder explorar do cosmo em
tempo só para citar um exemplo
numa conversa com o congro com grupo de
amigos em que nós mulheres discutíamos é
esta esta dificuldade é conciliar
trabalho em casa o marido filhos é e eu
vi umas amigas e apostou no que eu
chamaria de um feminismo moderado
nós já tínhamos essa idéia a dada altura
levantas um amigo nosso
já com ar bastante aborrecido e cansado
com aquilo que estávamos ali
z olha para nós esse sentimento disse
a vossa sorte é que vocês tenham bons
maridos e os deixa fazer isso meu
comentário foi completamente gesto foi
oportuno foi do mau tom eu feri a idéia
de que as mulheres que ficavam dentro e
fora de casa e ainda tinha ousadia da
aventura área para as outras atividades
que elas só faziam de vida com
descendência dos seus maridos e que
deveríamos ser grata nos autorizarem a
fazer isso tudo é chocante não é
eu achei eu achei duplamente chocante
não só pelo fato do comentário é ter
visto alguém tão jovem mas por uma
perceber que ainda nos dias de hoje está
com habitamos com aquela velha idéia de
que as mulheres tudo podem repetir-se em
ciências desde que os homens permitam
não na une nal para esse pensamento foi
o sonoro não eu defendo que as mulheres
independentemente da sua do seu estado
civil ou casadas viúvas ou ter enfim
devam prosseguir com aquilo que
acreditam e não esperarem seriamente a
aprovação de ninguém pra isso disse que
acredita realmente que estão certas e
que estão no bom caminho é preciso nós
mulheres expurgarmos qualquer pensamento
mal que nos faz duvidar de nós mesmas
para assim podermos ter o protagonismo
da nossa própria história é possível sim
conciliar trabalho e família amigos e
eventualmente alguma coisa exigirá mais
de nós
eles nada se você gostasse do que outras
mas é a vida isso é rotativo e ser
normal
o importante é que nos coloquemos sempre
a caminho
e nesse sentido eo também a experiência
só posso concluir que possam vir a ser a
mãe mais perfeita a profissional mais
perfeita
a empresária mais perfeita mas gostaram
eu sou seguramente uma mulher macho lixo
e eu sou feliz pelo simples fato de o
reconhecer que o esforço ea área mente
voltar então a questão inicial coloquei
qual tem sido verdadeiramente o lugar da
mulher nos dias de hoje
eu acredito que a mulher continua a
ocupar o papel crucial enquanto pilar da
família
isso é bom mas ela tem ganho cada vez
mais consciência de si mesma e tem
assumido com zelo e educação não só a
responsabilidade e inclusão de jogadas
mas principalmente a responsabilidade
que ela inspira que ela acredita em que
ela corra por taxa para agarrar ou seja
eu acredito que as mulheres têm cada vez
mais consciência do que o seu lugar em
todo o lado
por volta de reflexão ou mulher
até que ponto estão dispostas a serem
protagonistas das vossas próprias vidas
a protagonizarem os mais variados papéis
3 sendo acreditem sempre na vossa
versatilidade e não deixe nunca os
vossos sonhos sem um final feliz
[Música]